shuffling back into the classroom but
these students aren't quite as reluctant
as you'd expect they're being taught
eSports competitive video gaming it's a
booming industry especially in China the
world's biggest video game market
this isn't mindless button bashing it's
potentially a career but I do just like
can i you know you're a superconductor
[ __ ] they live breathe and eat video
games here at this Technical College
engine an eastern China they sleep them
to welcome to the dorm that dedication
is largely down to a surprising
benefactor the Chinese Communist Party
the CCP officially added eSports to the
National Curriculum and started offering
scholarships why well it's bite an
opportunity for China to dominate
competitively and for its gaming
companies to thrive but this is also a
tale of how the best intentions of an
authoritarian regime can have unintended
consequences I died from falling I'm not
doing very well it is but it is very
competitive not so long ago the Chinese
government picked eSports as a winner
put lots of resources behind it but now
it's having second thought it's changing
the rules of the game as it goes along
the reason is what the government's zeal
for video games has been doing to
China's eyes myopia short or
nearsightedness is on the rise among
young people
Jim I'm just a Korean so another pushing
major and a PhD todo que él tenía that
you know title it's not you know getting
your hustle you
by 2020 half the population of China
will have myopia that's around 700
million people may you Swan and Leasing
you are seven years old best friends and
visiting a Beijing hospital for a
regular eye test on this visit though
shinu is diagnosed with myopia it is
becoming an epidemic here function a guy
being Jewish or centralizes you allow
your daughter to rotate o the end of
time energy oh you Rio de Janeiro so
this is a technique from traditional
Chinese medicine to improve eyesight the
government is taking more dramatic
action they've frozen approvals for new
video games and are using national ID
cards to limit intuitive screen time
that's had another unforeseen effect
though it wiped billions of China's
video gaming companies even an unelected
regime struggles to be farsighted Tom
Cheshire Sky News engine an eastern
China
you